16h48 sur brut rémy buisine en direct je
me trouve avec yannick jadot europe
ecologie les verts tête de liste donc
aux élections européennes troisième
partie hier ils ont donc ramené de 13,47
% premier parti chez les jeunes les
18-24 ans 25% des voix on va donc en ont
parlé avec yannick jadot et vos
questions dans les commentaires
n'hésitez pas à réagir nsa apprendre les
meilleures questions et meilleures
tendances dans les commentaires réagir
aux propos yannick jadot mais aussi avec
vos questions à live donc que pouvez
commenter et partager
bonjour à vous unique jadot bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté l'invitation de
brut
cette première question cette réaction
donc au lendemain de ce que certains
annoncent comme une surprise pour vous
c'est vraiment véritablement une
surprise
non ce n'est pas une surprise parce que
c'est le pari qu'on s'était donné c'est
l'objectif qu'on s'était fixés les parce
qu'on n'a pas voulu tricher avec les
électrices et des électeurs
c'est à une élection européenne on a
parlé d'europe on est écologiste on a
parlé d'écologie et puis surtout je
pense qu'on est dans un moment où tout
le monde en a ras-le-bol de voter contre
de vote et résignés de voter par défaut
et on a voulu inciter proposé un vote
pour un vote pour l'avenir un vote pour
l'environnement pour le climat pour l
université pour la solidarité avec des
des réponses de terrain comme évidemment
des réponses à l'échelle européenne donc
on a respecté le scrutin on a surtout
respecter les électeurs et visiblement
c'était une bonne idée alors le ressenti
un peu moins de 24 heures après c'est
vrai que les sondages vous et les stylos
nous entoure de 8 9% finalement vous
terminez donc en troisième position avec
13 47
dans votre discours immédiatement après
vous dites nous sommes la troisième
force politique de france c'est à dire
au delà des clivages droite gauche
ah ben là c'est la troisième force
politique au sens où on arrive en force
politique écologie
que le troisième c'est pas au delà des
clivages droite gauche moi je fais pas
un trait d'union entre la gauche et la
droite et je sais que une bonne partie
des électeurs qui sont venus voter
europe écologie sont des électeurs de
gauche
et moi je connais les valeurs de
l'écologie c'est la justice sociale
c'est la solidarité
c'est le combat pour l'égalité des
droits contre l'homophobie contre la
xénophobie c'est la vie c'est le combat
pour les libertés donc on n'a pas de on
a pas d'ambiguïté sur nos valeurs mais
dans les rues toutes ces dernières
semaines à bruxelles comme à paris j'ai
aussi rencontré des jeunes qui me disait
pour nous le combat droite gauche est
totalement obsolète parce qu'en fait la
gauche comme la droite
ils ont elles ont maltraité le climat et
nous ce qu'on veut c'est lutter avec
détermination pour le climat et on sait
bien que si on lutte pour le avec
détermination pour le climat non
seulement on aura un avenir
ce qui est quand même pas si mal quand
on est jeune mais en plus il y aura plus
de solidarité aura plus de
réconciliation ce sera plus apaisée et
donc j'ai dire quoi voilà moi je suis de
gauche et vous je vous exclus parce que
vous n'avez pas compris le vieux système
politique du 20e siècle
non et ben moi je dis que je suis
écologiste que j'ai des valeurs qu'elles
sont la justice sociale la solidarité et
que notre objectif à nous écologistes
c'est de sortir du productivisme de
droite mais aussi du productivisme de
bouche
la question qui se pose aussi l'analyse
par rapport à hier on rappelle le
rassemblement national qui termine en
tête la république en marche un point
derrière environ je vois vous faites une
petite nous derrière par rapport à tout
ça c'est de se dire - rassemblement
national pour vous c'est quoi c'est un
vote de contestation c'était il ya deux
choses dans les extrêmes aura toujours
il y a probablement dans nos pays et ses
terribles 10 à 15% d'extrême droite qui
correspond vraiment à roger à du racisme
de la xénophobie ça malheureusement ces
présents dans une démocratie mais quand
on passe de 10 ou 15% à 25
il ya beaucoup de désarroi social
il ya beaucoup de votes pour renverser
la table en se disant vous rendez compte
ça depuis 2002 le deuxième tour de la
présidentielle entre chirac et le pen
depuis 2002 tous ceux qui gouvernent à
chaque échéance électorale
ils disent pas voté pour ce que j'ai
fait voter pour ce que je vous propose
voter parce que c'est moi ou le chaos
les gouvernements en place ne s'attaque
à l'extrême droite que lors des
échéances électorales et pour dire
faisait font fait unité derrière moi
contre l'extrême droite et donc tout ça
banalise l'extrême droite et tout ça a
créé pour ceux qui sont dans la
souffrance
pour ceux qui se sentent abandonnés mais
il se dit si le seul vote alternatif au
vote en place et l'extrême binger finir
par voter extrême droite parce que
finalement la jamais testé et puis pour
tous ceux qui se sont pas d'extrême
droite ils finissent par renoncer ne pas
voter
et donc c'est pour ça qu'on a une
incroyable responsabilité à créer une
alternative qui attaquent à la racine
les extrêmes droites pas simplement en
période électorale qui attaquent à la
racine les extrêmes droites et c'est
quoi s'attaquer aux racines et par
exemple dernière car m numéro 3 de ma
liste qui encore quelques jours avant
qu'ils rentrent au parlement européen et
maire de grande synthe dans le nord une
ville dure il ya 30 % de la population
sous le seuil de pauvreté un énorme taux
de chômage important de réfugiés et nama
attendait pourtant il a un des taux de
vote pour le front national pour le
l'extrême droite les plus faibles de sa
région pourquoi parce qu'il s'est occupé
des gens parce qu'il a répondu par
l'écologie la rénovation des logements
les transports publics y compris
ça a permis d'avoir des facilités de
déplacement et peut-être pouvoir
économiser une seconde voiture parce
qu'il fait du bio dans les cantines
parce qu'il réinstalle des paysans parce
qu'il a créé le minimum social garanti
qui fait que personne n'ait sous le
seuil de pauvreté
il vient de le mettre en place donc
l'écologie pour nous est la réponse aux
racines de l'extrême droite et c'est
pour ça qu'on dit finalement il ya le
pôle populiste aujourd'hui qui s'est
inscrit dans le paysage politique les
extrêmes droites qui sont à la conquête
partout en europe qui ceux qui sont de
plus en plus présent dans nos sociétés
en réalité il ya le pôle du monde
c'est le vieux monde de la gauche le
vieux monde de la droite réunie qui
défendent la technocratie qui défendent
la finance casino les énergies sales les
pesticides et puis à côté de ça il ya le
pôle écolo qui doit être le pôle de
l'espérance qui devait être le pôle de
l'espoir et des réponses au quotidien
aux défis des français comme à
accompagner leurs aspirations
un dernier point juste cette question
sociale
j'étais il ya quelques jours dans les
quartiers nord de marseille vient que
socialement dans les quartiers nord de
marseille
c'est dur et benque les habitants il me
disait quoi ils me disaient nous on
n'est pas des bobos on n'est pas des
bourgeois mais on exige l'écologie parce
que pour nous l'écologie c'est rénover
le logement alors qu'on est en grande
précarité énergétique que nos enfants
vont plus souvent que la moyenne
voir le médecin parce qu'ils sont
malades parce qu'il ya ils ont froid ou
que les murs sont son sont imbibées
d'eau et les tuyaux sont percées dont
ils ont d'énormes dépenses de flotte et
puis comme chaque parent il aimerait
bien avoir une alimentation saine pour
leurs enfants
donc l'écologie elle est sociale les
collégiens les solidaires les
collégiennes nous permet de retrouver
confiance et quand on retrouve confiance
dans l'avenir
et quand on retrouve confiance sur le
lieu où on habite
et bien la pub besoin de voter pour
l'extrême droite ont eu aussi leur gré
d'un manque d' allianz et raison ceux
qui vous soutiennent ça mais votre score
mais se disaient ont finalement c'est
dommage qui a peut-être pas eu une
meilleure alliance de la gauche ou avec
la liste de génération de la france un
soliste qui a aussi mis en avant le côté
écologique dans sa campagne
c'était impossible de réussir à unir
toutes les forces qui mettait en avant
l'écologie sur cette campagne je pense
même aussi à une autre liste qu'elle
faisait autour de 2% qui finalement
aurait peut-être fait des voix aussi
dans une liste unifiée
toutes les listes et notamment les lys
qui sont clairement l'écologiste on a
vocation à nous retrouver ça c'est pas
fait là c'est dommage mon époque quand
on a vocation à nous retrouver
après vous prenez par exemple l'exemple
de la france a soumises
moi je ne conteste pas un certain nombre
de responsables de la france a soumises
d'avoir intégré la question écologique
mais là on est dans une élection
européenne
nous on pense que les chiens
indispensable pour sauver climat pour
sauver le vivant c'est l'europe
on n'imagine pas pouvoir sauver les
dauphins qui s'échouent sur nos plages
éliminer le plastique dans les océans
protéger les abeilles les oiseaux éviter
la catastrophe climatique repliés
derrière des frontières
donc on a avec la france insoumise une
grande différence sur l'europe
eux ils sont prêts en sortir nous on
veut absolument y est pour la
transformer parce qu'on pense que vous
voyez rendez compte
moi je suis toujours super triste de
voir aujourd'hui les jeunes britanniques
qui manifestent dans les rues de lons de
l'ombre pour que la grande bretagne
reste en europe parce que la secoue dans
le monde d'aujourd'hui dans le monde
aussi petit aujourd'hui on leur a fermé
les portes du continent c'est pas un pro
et pour les pour les enfants et donc
quand nous avons des différences avec
les autres formations
ça rend ça nous rend pas incapable de
travailler sur certains sujets y compris
au parlement européen mais on n'a pas
les mêmes la même vision de l'union
européenne est moi ce que j'ai défendue
dans cette campagne c'est l'incohérence
savez la cohérence au parlement européen
c'est le groupe politique auquel vous
appartenez et ben quand vous votez vers
vous votez pour une député ou un député
vert qui va siéger dans le groupe vert
et c'est ce groupe là parce qu'on est
tellement sur la même ligne on a tous
tellement cette conviction autour de
l'environnement de là santé des libertés
que ça nous permet de gagner des combats
au parlement européen même si on n'est
pas le groupe majoritaire il n'y a pas
de groupe majoritaire mais les autres
vous avez les socialistes ils ont
rejoint le groupe socialiste et le
groupe socialiste il est pour les
accords de libre échange
la tête de liste socialiste pour cette
élection qu'elle l'actuel vice président
de la commission européenne forcément il
est pour le glyphosate
il est pour le dumping fiscal alors moi
j'ai ma cohérence sont les autres qui
malheureusement sont parfois un peu pas
forcément je dis pas qu'ils sont pas
sincères mais ils vont rejoindre des
groupes qui n'ont pas cette même
cohérence cette même conviction ce même
engagement contre les lobbys et pour
l'environnement
le temps pour parler du son sur plan
européen et la satisfaction du score on
l'a entendu mais d'un autre à
relativiser peut-être parce que moi
quand la dengue la liste des verts elle
fait 22% lors qu'est ce qui fait qu'en
france on n'arrive pas à avoir un score
qui pourrait titiller les sommets voire
même finir 2e premier essai l'objectif
l'objectif est pour vous qu en france on
n'a pas réussi le score on a un très
beau score
il ya une différence très forte en
allemagne c'est que en allemagne toutes
les élections sont à la proportionnelle
donc quand vous votez pour l'échéance
nationale à déchéance nationale chez eux
c'est pas une présidentielle
c'est voter pour le parlement pour le
moods un stack à la proportionnelle et
donc ils ont toujours des élus en
allemagne à chaque fois que vous mettez
un butin vers vous avez des élus en
france
vous mettez un bulletin vert pour les
européennes vous mettez un bulletin vert
pour les municipales pour les régionales
vous avez des élus vous mettez un
bulletin vert pour les élections
législatives par exemple eh ben la
plupart du temps vous n'avez pas d'élus
donc il ya une culture si vous les deux
d'avoir toujours des élus verts qui pèse
qui pèse toujours au bundestag même
quand ils n'ont pas de bons scores pour
leurs élections parlementaires dans la
sélection des initiatives ils ont
toujours 40 députés nous quand on fait
pas boire un beau score on a zéro
donc voyez une sorte de deux d'habitude
a voté à voter vert mais ce qui s'est
passé dans cette élection européenne
comme on le voit évoluer aussi dans le
benelux en belgique au luxembourg aux
pays bas comme en allemagne c'est que
l'écologie véritablement devient une
alternative à la fois je les dis
évidemment ce extrême droite et c'est
essentiel mais aussi à cette ultra la
veille libéralisme qui aujourd'hui
explose totalement les limites de la
planète qui organise un peu la
compétition de tous contre tous nous
fait perdre deux de sens dans la société
dans l'entreprise dans l'économie et
donc c'est ça qui va falloir
reconstruire dans les années qui
viennent et c'est pour ça que depuis
hier soir
nous nous avons la responsabilité de
tout notre travail au parlement repère
les alliances mais ce vote ce vote aussi
nous engage pour proposer une
alternative crédible
à l'échelle nationale française pour
conquérir le pouvoir
pour l'exercer parce qu'il est urgent
que l'écologie ouvert alors ce sont neuf
européens parce que c'est vrai qu'on a
eu tendance à voir centre et cela sans
scrutin national
c'est parfois dans dans l'analyse et
dans les votes mais et cette question de
se dire quelles alliances quel poids
vous allez avoir au niveau du parlement
européen aujourd'hui donc c'est à dire
avec les autres forces on peut parler
notamment je disais ça l'est en
allemagne qui a fait 22 % hier mais les
autres ce que vous pensez avoir un
groupe assez important est ce qu'on peut
peut-être mais aussi imaginer des
alliances avec la france un solide même
si vous avez dit qu'il ya des désaccords
mais est-ce que c'est peut-être
envisageable ce cas les discussions en
ce sens mais il ya donc au parlement
européen pains ce groupe n'est
majoritaire et il va y avoir dans les
jours qui viennent maintenant l'élection
du président de la commission européenne
il est élu il est proposé par des étapes
1 par les chefs de gouvernement et les
chefs d'état et il est le voter choisi
par le parlement européen
donc ça va être un moment on va se
dessiner un peu le mot va se dessiner le
mandat de la commission européenne
qu'elle va être un peu sa feuille de
route en fonction évidemment du résultat
des élections
nous ce qu'on a toujours fait
écologistes au parlement européen c'est
pas des coalitions avec la droite et la
gauche à la droite à gauche et les
libéraux se sont toujours réparti les
postes autour d'un projet qui est quand
même le projet techno libéral qui
gouvernent l'europe aujourd'hui nous ce
qu'on a toujours fait c'est d'essayer de
créer des collisions mais autour de
sujets quand on gagne quand la pêche
électrique on gagne pas tout seul
notre groupe n'a pas la majorité donc il
faut convaincre d'autres députés
quand tu es aujourd'hui ce qu'on veut
faire c'est gagner sur le climat faire
que l'europe adapte toutes ces
politiques publiques à l'objectif de 1
5% de réchauffement maximum
de la planète donc ça veut bien dire par
exemple éliminer toutes les subventions
aux énergies fossiles
taxer les pollueurs ça veut aussi dire
évidemment un plan massif d'isolation
des logements c'est combattre la vie
chère de nos concitoyens ça veut dire
développer les énergies renouvelables et
avoir des entreprises partout et ne plus
dépendre de poutine de trains coût des
dictatures du golfe et donc c'est sur
ces sujets là qu'on va essayer de
construire des côtes et des majorités
pour faire que l'europe évolué fortement
qu'en à les six corps bien qu'ils aient
débuté de la france soumise dit il n'a
pas fait une campagne de gauche qu'est
ce que vous lui répondez vous savez le
problème je crois dans cette campagne
c'est que la france a soumis s'est
intéressé aux autres campagnes plutôt
que de parler de son projet moi j'ai dit
dans cette campagne j'ai été en
permanence attaqué sur les réseaux
sociaux
ça a été quand même souvent une chasse
en meute contre moi je vais vous
présenter si j'étais leur ennemi il je
pense qu'ils se sont trompés de
l'adversaire si on doit avoir un ennemi
en politique c'est l'extrême droite
pour le reste je pense qu'on fait de la
politique en proposant des solutions
pour le quotidien des français là des
européens pour leur avenir pour se
réconcilier pour avoir un débat apaisé
dans la société
ils ont choisi de faire de moi leurs
adversaires moi mon agresseur c'est le
dérèglement climatique
c'est la destruction du vivant c'est le
délitement des solidarités donc je crois
que finalement les français on le prend
on récompensait ceux qui portaient des
propositions plutôt que des
stigmatisations il ya aurélien barrau
qui est un astrophysicien c'est connu il
connaissait aussi qu'on a eu en invité
sur route il ya quelques semaines je
mets d'ailleurs ceux qui n'ont rien le
répète ce live est disponible sur
youtube avec 7
cette analyse où finalement il ya vu un
peu tempérer les choses ou sur twitter
et dit finalement juste un peu plus
d'une personne sur dix a jugé que la fin
du monde était une thématique
prioritaire on a parlé d'un danger
existentiel que la vie sur terre était
en train de se nourrir que la sixième
cette action majeure se déployait
finalement
qu'une personne sur dix qui vote écolo
en france alors il ya la satisfaction
d'un côté mais de se dire que finalement
vers exemple faut qu'on gagne il n'y a
pas d'alternative faut qu'on gagne parce
que nous sommes les seuls à agir
concrètement
je pense qu'il ya aussi un peu de
confusion de la part de nos concitoyens
des deux types de questionnements 1
puisque les autant par six en parle
c'est quelque part ils doivent faire
quelque chose
donc il a fallu pendant toute cette
campagne démontré qu' il y en à
l'écologie à ceux qui ont parlé et puis
à ce qu'ils agissent et il ya ceux qui
au fond dont l'écologie s'arrêter où
commencent les intérêts des lobbys et
puis il ya ce nom qui combattons
toujours ces lobbys pour agir donc on a
eu ce moment de clarification et puis je
crois que nous devons continuer à
convaincre continuer à convaincre la
transition écologique elle et pas
simplement indispensable elle et pas
simplement urgente elle peut être
positive que l'on va accompagner les
agriculteurs dans la sortie des
pesticides qu'on va accompagner les
salariés dans la sortie du diesel et
voyez qu'on que que que le projet écolo
parce qu'il re localise l'économie parce
que eux ils créent beaucoup d'emplois à
l'échelle locale et des emplois de
qualité dans délocalisables parce qu'ils
s'intéressent à la culture à la santé à
l'éducation au fond va ce projet là va
construire une société plus apaisée pu
réconcilier où on se projette avec plus
de sérénité dans l'avenir et c'est ce
cette démonstration là qu'on a peut-être
sur laquelle on n'a pas encore
totalement convaincu mais c'est notre
défi on n'a pas le choix tu as an est un
terme que l'on entend de plus en plus
c'est celui de la la décroissance ou dit
qu'il faudrait décroître justement pour
éviter cette catastrophe est ce que
justement quand on est une personnalité
politique on se retrouve au milieu ben
voilà est cette idée se dire on a un peu
le la concurrence des pays
les uns envers les autres d'avoir la
plus forte croissance est ce que c'est
un terme que vous pouvez vous partager
et enfin moi quelle est votre position
sur le thème de la décroissance alors
c'est notre jeu terme 1 c'est un vieux
thème de la décroissance 1 mais si vous
voulez il est ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est qu'aujourd'hui la croissance
c'est l'augmentation du produit
intérieur brut
ça n'a plus aucun sens y compris pour
les économistes
si les gens sont davantage malades ils
prennent davantage de médicaments
et ça ça fait de la croissance si vous
faites une énorme marée noire ça crée de
l'activité de dépollution ça fait de la
croissance et donc ce concept il dit pas
du tout notre bien-être il dit pas du
tout si on est plus ou moins heureux si
on a plus ou moins de bien-être si on a
plus ou moins accès aux services publics
si on a une meilleure santé une
meilleure éducation si notre avenir est
préservé donc en fait le terme de
décroissance c'est pour ses concepteurs
ce qu'ils appelaient un terme au but
c'est à dire cet interne pour
démystifier la croissance parce que la
croissance du carbone c'est une
saloperie pour l'environnement la
croissance des maladies c'est une
saloperie évidemment pour notre santé en
revanche nous ce qu'on veut c'est la
croissance des services publics c'est la
croissance d'une année d'une d'une
alimentation de qualité c'est la
croissance des énergies renouvelables
mais la décroissance du charbon du
pétrole et du nucléaire
donc en fait faut aujourd'hui racontait
une histoire qui n'est pas une histoire
anti économique
on a besoin aujourd'hui de l'économie
pour faire cette grande transition
il nous faut des transports collectifs
il nous faut des énergies renouvelables
il nous faut des artisans qui zonent au
logement il nous faut de la croissance
de l'agriculture biologique et la
décroissance des pesticides
donc c'est ça qui vous raconte justement
quand on parle aussi des croissances ont
un plus aussi jeune qui nous regardent
aujourd'hui alors je vous cite aussi
quelque part en vrille un barreau qu'on
avait reçu il ya deux semaines qui me
disait c'est aussi l'idée de ne plus
être forcément à la mode plus vouloir
avoir le dernier téléphone portable qui
voyait des évolutions tous les 6 mois de
ne pas vouloir acheter forcément des
vêtements qui ont été produits à l'aube
ou du monde parce que c'est notre marque
favorite est ce que c'est finalement un
un changement de raisonnement que doit
avoir l'humain vis-à-vis de sa façon de
consommer au quotidien
c'est vrai pour ça qu'ils n'ont pas le
plus souvent du pouvoir de vivre que du
pouvoir d'achat bien sûr on a tous
besoin de manger de s'habiller donc mais
le pouvoir d'achat renvoie un acte de
consommation alors que le pouvoir de
vivre renvoie à des actes mais qui sont
liées à la qualité de la vie mais il est
évident que dans un monde qui est très
angoissé aujourd'hui très instable ce
que nous propose le capitalisme pouvons
aller au stade où les c'est toujours de
gérer nos angoisses de gérer les
incertitudes de l'avenir par une
consommation compulsive pas acheter
toujours plus acheter renouveler encore
et encore et c'est vrai que de ce point
de vue là la sobriété une forme de
sobriété
ça peut être bénéfique évidemment pour
la paire être mais aussi pour nous même
ne pas considérer que finalement plutôt
galets je sais pas quoi avec des amis le
dimanche
au théâtre au ciné ou taper dans un
ballon
on va aller dans un centre commercial
pour consommer donc on a deux ans
d'assurer pour limiter au fond l'achat
compulsif
mais attention il ya quand même toute
une partie de la population qui n'a pas
assez de pouvoir de vivre qui se
chauffent mal qui se nourrit mal qui se
déplacent mal qui se soit une malle qui
s'éduque uc duc nal parce qu'ils n'ont
pas assez de capacité à obtenir ces
biens ou ses services
donc il faut distinguer à la fois ce que
peut être une consommation compulsive
dont il faut sortir d'une consommation
nécessaire qu'il faut arriver à
satisfaire
et justement ça me rebondit aussi sur le
capitalisme ce que le capitalisme et
l'écologie sont compatibles le
capitalisme financier qui bousillent la
planète qui organise la guerre de tous
contre tous et qui organise aussi la
guerre contre l' économie réelle
les taux de rentabilité qui sont exigés
du capital financier n'ont plus rien à
voir avec l'économie réelle
ça empêche parfois aux entreprises
d'investir sur la durée de recruter sur
la durée jusqu'à la caricature ou des
entreprises ont les actions qui monte en
bourse parce qu'elle licencie donc ce
système là aujourd'hui les pervers il
est pervers pour la planète
il est pervers pour nous donc
incontestablement le capitalisme est
incompatible avec l'écologie cette cette
question qui se pose donc dans les
commentaires plusieurs personnes du fait
de s'allier à la république en marche
pour parlement européen ce que c'est
envisageable ou pas du tout c'est une
question qui est revenue plusieurs fois
mais c'est ce que j'ai dit à l'heure sur
les courts politique savait la
république en marche
ils vont rejoindre le groupe libéral
le groupe libéral et pour tous les
accords de libre échange je suis
peut-être le député au parlement
européen le plus connu dans son combat
contre les accords de libre échange
souvent ils parlent d'environnement
il parle de climat 2010 la cité mais il
refuse d'avoir des objectifs
contraignants pour les entreprises ou
pour les états et considère que
finalement on peut parfaitement confié à
monsanto la sortie du glyphosate nous
pour nous c'est pas notre cas donc ça
nous empêche pas que sur certains votes
comme il faut être majorité 1 pour
gagner mais on va essayer de les
convaincre
quand on a gagné contre la pêche
électrique l'un des autres acteurs de ce
combat là ces pays onuci margie de la
france insoumise
mais y en avait aussi chez les libéraux
qui voulait lutter contre la pêche
industrielle qui détruit les écosystèmes
et qui élimine les pêcheurs artisans
donc sur les sujets parfois on arrive à
se retrouver
et puis sur d'autres sujets on est en
opposition frontale donc tu aura pas
d'alliance deux groupes n'y a pas
d'alliance du groupe et vous êtes vous
retrouvé maître sur des vols communs sur
bien sûr malheureusement c'est comme ça
que parlement européen fonctionne
sinon on n'avance plus si on se dit moi
je suis dans mon groupe et c'est mon
groupe et rien d'autre et rien qu'à lens
si tout le monde fait ça y est rien car
ans donc même la france insoumise qui
dit toujours nouveau on est dans le coin
on trahit jamais jamais copié cieux qui
font des compromis sinon on fait pas
évoluer le droit sinon protège pas à la
santé sinon on n'est pas responsable
notre responsabilité c'est pas dans la
posture notre responsabilité c'est agir
de trouver le meilleur compromis pour
les européens et dans la société il ya
des contradictions il ya des différences
mais à un moment donné faut essayer de
se rassembler quand même la question qui
se pose justement serait qu'on regarde
beaucoup ce qui se passe du côté de
l'assemblée nationale mais ça n'a rien à
voir mais on regarde beaucoup moins ce
qui se passe au par les loyers que
lorsque l'assemblée nationale c'est vous
êtes dans la majorité
vous êtes un
d'un parlementaire godillots souvent
dire que le gouvernement vous dit voter
pour ou étaient pour
et puis vous êtes dans l'opposition on
vous dit voté contre a voté contre
donc c'est le gouvernement qui a le
pouvoir dans notre système politique là
au parlement européen c'est bien les
parlementaires qui ont le pouvoir et
encore une fois il n'y a pas de majorité
et d'opposition se veut pas dire qu'il
ya pas des sensibilités et à la
sensibilité générale quand même au
parlement européen c'est plutôt libérale
mais c'est parce que les électeurs ont
voté pour ces majorité l'a donc à nous
de convaincre les électeurs de
construire d'autres majorités finalement
faso au point des lobbys on a pu voir
également la tentative de nicolas hulot
au sein du gouvernement qui s'est soldée
par une démission un peu plus d'un an
après son entrée au gouvernement
c est ce que c'est possible de réussir à
faire de l'écologie qui influencent le
monde
en politique c'est ce qu'on fait au
parlement européen c'est ce que fait
j'ai parlé de damien carême à
grande-synthe
c'est ce qu'on fait au niveau local dans
plein de villes c'est ce qu'on fait dans
certaines régions c'est l'impuissance
quelques soirées se déroulent dans des
lots bien ou pas faut pas se construire
les lobbys sont là faut les combattre
nous le groupe écologiste on a fermé les
portes à monsanto et on a obtenu devant
la cour européenne de justice la
transparence sur les études de monsanto
alors qu'on sait qu'ils ont falsifié
beaucoup de science donc il faut lutter
conter lobby mais il n'y a pas un lobby
qui vous impose quoi que ce soit un
moment donné c'est la responsabilité
d'élu et nous ce qu'on revendique c'est
courage le courage en politique pour
agir
qu'est ce qui nous empêche de sortir du
nucléaire en 15 20 ans et de les
remplacer par des énergies nouvelles
rien qu'est ce qui nous empêche
d'investir dans l'isolation des besoins
rien qu'est ce qui nous empêche de
choisir les agriculteurs bio par rapport
à monsanto par rapport à bayer rien
sinon courage politique
nuon la de le faire on gagne parfois on
perd souvent trop souvent et on voit que
le fait que nous perdions trop souvent
la pollution de l'air augmente les
pesticides augmente
le dérèglement climatique s'accélère
donc il va être temps que les écolos
prennent la main les couvrir et voile
évoque le départ de nicolas hulot vous
l'avez vécu le comment parce que l'on
peut imaginer
sûrement pas mal de points de
convergence avec ses idées c'est se dire
bon mais seulement voilà t'il personnes
qui influent vécu avec tristesse son
état j'ai vécu avec tristesse parce que
vous savez quand vous êtes écologistes
vous attendez pas tous les cinq ans pour
savoir s'en va devenir écolo pas quand
les scientifiques qui vous disent on a
12 ans pour traiter la question du
climat
peut-être moins pour traiter la question
de la biodiversité vous dit pas ah ben
tiens j'ai perdu
ciao on se retrouve dans cinq ans et
puis si je perds bas cette torpille
s'est totalement perdu le pari nicolas
hulot c'est de dire il ya un nouveau
président la république qu'il est jeune
il veut changer les choses
eh ben je l'écologie mais je vais
écologiser ses politiques
malheureusement c'est un extraordinaire
gâchis puisque nicolas hulot après
partie parce que le président de la
république n'a pas agi à renoncer sur
l'écologie il a renoncé sur la justice
sociale et donc ça a été un moment de
tristesse parce que son échec c'est laid
ça veut dire qu'il ya de l'inaction du
côté du gouvernement sait jamais une
bonne nouvelle et son échec est aussi un
moment de clarification c'est à dire qu
emmanuel mâcon qui fait des grands
discours sur l'écologie
finalement quand il s'agit d'agir il
fait pareil comment vous voulez faire
les viol au bi ou à la protection du
climat et de la planète
comment vous jugez justement l'action
des mêmes un conte du gouvernement
c'était maintenant deux ans qui sont au
pouvoir encore un petit peu de recul sur
l'or sur leur action très franchement
votre avis sur la politique française en
matière d'écologie vraiment pas à la
hauteur des
fille on n'est pas à la hauteur des
défis pour éviter le chaos climatique
pour éviter l'anéantissement de la
biodiversité
mais ce qui est incroyable c'est
qu'aujourd'hui les réponses ont les
seins et ses réponses
elle crée de l'emploi elle crée les
entreprises elles créent de la culture
de la démocratie
elles maintiennent les services publics
donc toutes les solutions aux crises
écologiques elles sont là et c'est ça
qui est terriblement frustrant par
contre il faut savoir choisir entre une
pme est une multinationale
il faut savoir choisir entre un artisan
et un lobby il faut savoir choisir entre
un mari culture bio ou un paysan bio ou
un agriculteur qui est tout seul sur 300
hectares où kim et des centaines de
vaches dans une dans une dans une ferme
usines ça encore une fois c'est le
courage politique et on l'a encore vu
dernièrement finalement emmanuel macron
en revenant sur le terrain de l'écologie
pendant la campagne électorale qu'est ce
qu'il a dit implicitement à tous les
français il a dit j'ai peur du vote
d'europe écologie donc je vais faire
froid que je vais agir donc lui-même
disait en fait j'agis pas pour sauver le
climat ou pour sauver la biodiversité
j'agis pour limiter le succès des
écologistes donc implicitement il
appelait à voter europe écologie
le poids des lobbys aujourd'hui
justement on en parle beaucoup il ya eu
il ya une
deux semaines maintenant les révélations
du monde et de france 2 sur un fichier
bayer monsanto sud donnant une notation
sur les gens qui sont pour ou contre le
glyphosate avec des personnalités
politiques avec des journalistes
également on voit que ce poids des
lobbys aujourd'hui il est extrêmement
important
concrètement ce poids des lobbys et
complet au niveau du parlement européen
dans votre quotidien est ce que vous
êtes
abb est ce que vous pouvez avoir des
pressions ce que vous ressentez
aujourd'hui ce point les lobby
extrêmement influent sur les politiques
sur le plan européen au niveau du
parlement européen où je rappelle que
vous étiez il est très important il est
très important parce que il ya des
décisions essentielles qui se prennent
au niveau européen si on a des dizaines
de milliers de le beast niveau européen
c'est parce que c'est là aujourd'hui
qu'on définit les règles en matière de
finances en matière de pesticides ou
d'énergie ou de pollution des voitures
donc évidemment toutes les activités
économiques ont des représentants mais
si vous voulez le le choix que là la
principale source du lobby ou sa
principale visibilité c'est pas la
corruption y avait encore de la
corruption y en a sûrement mais c'est
pas j'oublie cette enveloppe et vous
voter comme je vous dis de voter c'est
ça peut être plus pernicieux que ça
quand vous êtes député européen vous
pourriez passer toutes vos soirées
invité par des entreprises vous pourriez
participer régulièrement à des week-ends
où vous emmenez votre famille on vous
demande pas de dire le contraire de ce
que vous pensez mais simplement vous
voyez bien que si vous êtes invités avec
votre famille à malte pour discuter des
grands projets imposé d'autoroute ou
d'aéroport vous n'avez pas forcément la
même force après vis-à-vis de ce lobby
et puis une des entrées très forte des
lobbys aujourd'hui qu'il faut
véritablement combattre c'est la
recherche sur tous nos sujets quand on
parle de monsanto et du glyphosate donc
bercé par les commentaires juste
une personne personne ne dit que ça a
été extrêmement simple de déterminer que
le glyphosate et est cancérogène donc
les responsables politiques comme les
gouvernements il se positionne sur le
caractère cancérogène du glyphosate en
fonction des études qui sont présentés
par des scientifiques mais si vous avez
dans les agences qui font les
recommandations scientifiques des
personnes qui travaillent en même temps
pour l'agrochimie
vous voyez bien que là le système est
totalement pernicieux et comme tout ces
dernières années on a réduit les
financements de la recherche publique
une bonne partie des chercheurs publics
aujourd'hui ils vivent grâce à des
contrats avec des entreprises
donc voyez on est dans un système où il
ya beaucoup de conflits d'intérêts et on
arrive près à savoir si parfois un avis
scientifique est indépendant ou s'il
sert simplement les intérêts de la firme
et donc il faut véritablement à la fois
mettre de l'argent dans la recherche
publique pour qu'on ait une recherche
indépendante et puis attaquer tous les
conflits d'intérêts et c'est vraiment le
boulot que portent les écologistes au
parlement européen arraché les conflits
d'intérêts bas des processus de décision
et puis quand vous disiez sortir les
lobbys du parlement européen
le glyphosate justement depuis début ce
direct il ya énormément de personnes qui
en parle et on remercie toutes celles et
ceux qui suit ce challenge rappelle que
vous pouvez réagir poser vos questions
est également partagé ce direct alors le
glyphosate justement c'est une personne
se dit mais comment ça se fait qu'on
n'arrive pas à l'interdire immédiatement
dès maintenant qu'est-ce qui bloque
finalement les lobbys
mais les lobbys et puis ce qu'il renvoie
j'étais il ya il ya quelques semaines
avec paul françois un poil françois est
un céréalier du1 brut dessus et un
céréalier de charente qui a été malade
d'un produit de chez monsanto qui a fait
un procès qui a gagné au bout de douze
ans il a 250 240 hectares de céréales et
bien depuis qu'il est malade il est
sorti des pesticides donc eu des paysans
qui vivent sans glyphosate qui
travaillent sans glyphosate il y en a de
plus en plus et de l'autre côté on
connaît de plus en plus étrange est
réelle du glyphosate
donc on a un problème on a la solution
mais l'agrochimie ça fait partie des
plus grosses firmes au monde
ça fait partie de ceux qui ont table
ouverte à matignon à bercy ou à l'elysée
alors que le paysan bio aujourd'hui
compris touche même pas toutes ces aides
vous voyez donc il ya toujours ce
rapport de force entre les grosses
entreprises
quand beaucoup d'argent quand beaucoup
de capacités de lobby et puis ceux qui
font sens et puis vous savez il ya une
saleté quoi la stratégie de monsanto et
ça que je reste coi la stratégie de
monsanto
c'est comme le lobby des cigarettes ou
où le lobby pendant longtemps du pétrole
c'est de fabriquer du tout
à chaque fois qu'il y avait une étude
indépendante qui disait le qu'il faut
that est en danger il financer ce
inquiétude pour dire non ya pas de
problème et donkey il organise dans la
société et ça a été ça aussi la
révélation du fichier c'est qu'en fait
ils ont dévoilé parmi les journalistes
ils ont dévoilé parmi les élus qui
disent oui il en fait on est sûrement
n'est pas sûr alors si on n'est pas sûr
pour quoi embêter les gens ont faut
faire un peu plus de recherche
le truc c'est jamais de dire on est sûr
arrêter nous embêter se dire oui mais on
va refaire encore quelques années de
recherche
et puis comme il faut faire des
recherches pour quoi embêter les gens en
sortir alors qu'on n'est pas sûr et donc
c'est en permanence la fabrique du doute
sur la réalité scientifique et donc la
fabrique de l'inaction c'est comme ça
que ça marche il ya une question qui se
pose beaucoup en ce moment
cette peur justement et que les
mouvements sociaux le mouvement des
filets jaunes qui au mois novembre
dernier est né notamment de 7,2 ce rejet
des taxes contre la hausse des prix du
carburant c'est finalement se dire
comment on arrive à allier ce qu'on
appelle fin du monde et fin du mois à
avoir une transition écologique qui en
même temps ne soit pas à prendre d euros
supplémentaires dans le portefeuille de
ceux qui en ont le moins
et bien moi je vous ai raconté ça un peu
au début de cet entretien
quand quand damien carême il fait les
transports publics gratuits à la fois
c'est une facilité pour se transporter
et d'ailleurs il ya une utilisation deux
fois plus importante
une fréquentation deux fois plus
importante des transports du coup sûr le
grand dunkerque et ça permet
d'économiser pour certaines familles la
seconde voiture ckpa 5000 euros par an
quand on investit massivement et c'est
ce qu'on demande depuis des années dans
l'isolation des logements
ces 400 500 600 700 euros d'économie de
chauffage par an et ça crée des bouleaux
d'artisans quand donc notre écologie à
la lecture sociale elle est toujours
solide et c'est pendant trente ans on a
dit attention avec le tout tgv on en
train de fermer les yeux
ce qu'on appelle les les lignes
secondaires ou les petites lignes et
puis les gars attention avec
l'autorisation de faire que des grandes
surfaces en périphérie
parce que non seulement ça bousille des
terres agricoles ou ça bousille la
nature mais en plus il ya plus de petits
commerces vous êtes obligés de faire 15
bornes avec votre voiture pour aller
faire des courses
attention à garder des services publics
de proximité
sinon pour aller voir le médecin vous
allez faire 20 km ou 30 km donc en fait
il ya un système qui a organisé la
dépendance à la voiture et ça il faut en
sortir parce que moi j'ai un picardie et
ma mère elle vit toujours en picardie
il est pas question qu elle arrête
d'avoir une voiture met donc à la fois
faux créé le système pour qu'on ait
moins besoin de la voiture ou que quand
on se serve de la voiture ça soit sur
des distances moins quand
et puis tout ce qu'on a toujours dit sur
la fiscalité écologique depuis plus de
dix ans chaque euro prélevé doit être
rendu aux français pour les accompagner
dans la transition et pour investir et
donc c'est ce que n'ont pas fait les
gouvernements les gouvernements ils ont
compensé la fin de l'isf
la baisse de la fiscalité sur l'épargné
sur le capital par la fiscalité écolo
donc ça rend tout le monde dingue
et puis enfin dernier point c'est pas
normal de payer 50 60 % de taxes sur son
diesel ou sur son essence et puis que le
kérosène des avions soient pas imposées
ou le fioul lourd qu'est le transport
maritime donc le transport de la vie d'y
aller la mondialisation soit pas imposé
donc justice fiscale justice sociale et
puis surtout investissements pour nous
donner les moyens justement de réduire
nos dépenses et de combattre la vie
chère notamment la voiture l'idc les
primes la conversion les et les brimer
la conversion et puis c'est le boulot
sur les normes et le carburant ou fait
pour le maïs est quand même mais c'est
et puis c'est le parce que quand votre
facture de carburant ces deux choses
c'est le prix et la quantité moi ça fait
15 ans que je me bats avec les syndicats
et avec les consommateurs pour que les
constructeurs automobiles respectent les
normes de pollution et de consommation
aujourd'hui les bagnoles elle pollue 40%
de plus que la norme
on a 60 7000 morts que nature et par an
dans le pays et à la pollution de l'air
et on a des constructeurs automobiles
qui trichent avec les normes mais en
trichant avec les normes de pollution
ils trichent en même temps que les
normes de consommation dès qu'on a les
constructeurs automobiles appliquerait
les normes qu'ils indiquent
respecter mais qu'ils fraudent qu'il
triche on aurait on économisait 4 à 500
euros de carburant par an donc il faut
aussi contraindre les constructeurs
automobiles à respecter les normes et
aller vers des voitures qui consomment
moins mais faut-il augmenter les taxes
oui oui il ya des taxes sur les
carburants
c'est les taxes qui permettent de
financer la transition et sous les
augmenter nous ce qu'on voulait c'est ce
qu'on vous ait fait assez y compris
comme dans les pays du nord
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait dans les pays
du nord ils ont mis la taxe carbone est
beaucoup plus élevée que la nôtre
simplement pour les populations les plus
vulnérables ce qu'ils payent en taxe
carbone eh ben il ya une réduction
d'impôt pour qu' il n'y ait pas de coût
pour eux ils ont la couche sociale pour
qu'on pense à des plus vulnérables ondes
et compense cette fois d'une
augmentation mais en même temps une
compensation pour les plus vénérables et
puis pour ceux qui ont les moyens
et bien cela il faut aussi qu'ils
changent de comportement pareil et la
question qui se pose il nous reste
quelques petits instants parce qu'après
vous êtes vous êtes attendus justement
sur l'idée de se dire au parlement
européen
finalement ça va être quoi vos premières
actions vos chantiers principaux dans
les prochains jours ou les prochaines
semaines les prochains mois qu'on y voie
clair nous y revoilà maintenant ils sont
élus ils ont plus de députés qui n'en
avait à l'époque comment ils vont faire
qu'est ce qu'ils vont nous laisser c'est
qu'on allait mettre en place un comité
citoyen de surveillance et d'initiatives
sur l'europe lors ça peut pas être tous
les cinq ans on vote on est une petite
campagne on vote et dire qu'on s'y
intéresse plus nous on va avoir un
comité avec des acteurs de la société
civile des personnes de l'entreprise des
syndicats de la recherche qui vont tous
les mois dire c'est quoi l'agenda de
l'europe
comment le parlement européen vote et
comment potentiellement sur des sujets
on peut se mobiliser l'idée c'est que
rendre l'europe vivante et rendent
l'europe citoyenne et transparente ça
c'est ce qu'on va mettre en place mais
il ya deux grands chantiers qui arrive
c'est la réforme de la politique
agricole commune la politique agricole
commune c'est 40% du budget européen
en france aujourd'hui c'est 9 milliards
d'euros d'argent public qui tombent tous
les ans sur l'agriculture française et
donc nous
que cet argent là à la fois il ya un
revenu décent pour les paysans et qui
consorte des pesticides donc ça c'est un
des grands chantiers et puis le deuxième
grand chantier ça reste le chantier du
climat aujourd'hui l'europe ne respecte
pas l'accord de paris sur le climat
parce qu'on n'a pas d'ambition assez
élevées en matière de réduction des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre ni en
matière de développement des énergies
renouvelables de réduction de
consommation d'énergie vous rendez
compte que en europe il ya toujours 50 5
milliards d'euros de subventions
publiques par an aux énergies fossiles
celle dont il faut absolument sortir
pour sauver le climat donc voilà par
exemple de très grands chantiers
auxquels on va s'atteler et on vend les
très heureux de s'y atteler à beaucoup
plus d'emplois puisque notre groupe est
passé globalement de 52 à plus de 70
députés
cette question de fabrice dans les
commentaires qui nous dit quid en état
d'urgence climatique déclaré en europe
très bien mais la question vous savez
moi je suis pour
évidemment on est en réalité dans un
état d'urgence climatique
mais si vous laissez pas le déclarer ça
ne constitue pas encore une action la
seule chose qu'il faut faire aujourd'hui
c'est agir
le problème c'est que les dirigeants
européens trop souvent et ce pays de
meaux ils disent on a fait l'accord de
paris il faut respecter la cour de paris
le climat c'est l'urgence est la
priorité absolue de l'humanité et puis
une fois qu'ils ont fini de discours il
continue avec total qui continue avec
edf et le nucléaire
il continue avec le lobby automobile et
ils ont bien pour le climat la seule
chose qui compte c'est pas les mots
c'est pas les déclarations c'est
l'action et cette action aujourd'hui
elle est d'autant plus urgente que le
climat s'emballe est d'autant plus
bénéfique que ça crée de l'emploi
partout et l'anc tout dans la question
vos rapports avec d'anciennes figures
d'europe écologie les remparts le de
cohn-bendit du look enfin qui pour
certains ont choisi de partir de l'autre
côté alors hulot il est revenue
ah mais on est un parti pendant un
moment où télécom gagne avec rooney sert
on continue à se parler avec dali code
d'éthique maintenant on est en désaccord
savez moi j'ai participé à la fondation
d'europe écologie en 2009 et notre but
c'était d'avoir le groupe vers le plus
puissant parlement au cap à ce que nous
disions que on se disait déjà c'est le
groupe verts qui gagnent sur les
libertés sur la santé sur
l'environnement et bien moi je poursuis
cette ambition après ceux qui ont choisi
d'aller écologiser le président de la
république
je pense que ils ont pas un bilan qui
est très long sur la feuille en matière
de victoire sur l'écologie alors que
nous qui sommes restés fidèles à europe
écologie on peut mettre sur un papier
noir sur blanc ce qu'on a gagné au
parlement européen au niveau local ou au
niveau national à ces mots de la fin et
que vous ayez merci d'eau merci à vous
pour ces 45 minutes d'entretien
je rappelle votre score 13,47 % ces
élections savoir millions c'est le plus
gros score qu'en effet en termes de voix
dans l'histoire de l'écologie politique
en france par deux en 2009 vous avez
fait 16 % avec la moralisation avait
plus de participation vous entends déjà
lire je suis très heureux je les dis est
très enthousiaste que les jeunes aient
choisi e et placé l'écologie comme
première force politique prof tranche
d'âge ça c'est enthousiasmant
c'est une sacrée responsabilité mais
c'est enthousiasmant et ben merci à vous
et vous je rappelle cette interview
disponible en intégralité en effet tout
de suite sur facebook on mettra aussi
sur youtube dans les prochaines heures
merci à toutes et tous d'avoir suivi ce
direct et puis on se retrouve très vite
pour de nouvelles images en direct sur
brut merci à vous bonne fin de journée
et à très bientôt
merci merci encore